are you guys going to be part of next
week's show live from the castle as only
we could do
which is fantastic
let's talk about that quick judge you
save at the end did Katie and you guys
all huddle and decide oh let me tell you
exactly what happened okay Katie brought
us in because whoever gets to do it by
themselves gets hate mail for the rest
of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
on so so when she turned around and said
hey you guys let's talk about this it
just threw us under the bus because Luke
and I didn't want any parts of that
that's what we call strength and numbers
you understand so as soon as she said
that we said we're done
no but you know it's at this point right
now
believe it or not I mean think about
this we're going to go down to one
which is impossible I mean when I say
this what I said on the show was correct
and you talk you want to be a stylist
you want to be a stylist two seconds
into your song you know exactly who's
singing each one of them has their own
lane now so it just depends on what Lane
makes it so what was it about Oliver
that you guys thought you know we need
to see more of them I just think the
fact that he's got a little if we push
him forward if we there's a lane for him
in other words in the recording business
what would be the easiest one to say put
a record out and they'll go somewhere he
would be that person opposed to trying
to say well work it we'll work it and
it's not that we're taking away the the
others in terms of their talent it's
just we want to have them make
that goal record you saw on stage one of
those
we're gonna miss you next week but
Alanis Morissette and Ed Sheeran not bad
replacement I saw Katie Katie got kind
of worried she said well wait I said
Katie is just a replacement for one
night don't get nervous and then I saw
Ed Sheeran I said I don't know I didn't
know it
the contestants reaction there oh and of
course they rushed they rushed the
camera I kept saying no Ed's not here uh
everybody no can I tell you something to
get Ed and Atlantis to do this is just
amazing it just tells you to the power
of the show and the contestants are
gonna love it because that's equal
amount of pressure and they get to see
what other artists look like and feel
like it's gonna be good now Lionel did
you get a say on who got to replace you
next week
the idea is you want to make sure that
this experience by the way when you do
this this is the greatest experience in
the world I mean I didn't realize how
much fun we were going to have when we
said yes to this six years ago can we
talk about that six years but it it goes
by because we're building now artists
these are not just singers these guys
are going ladies and gentlemen are going
on now to do fabulous things in terms of
the real business that's what you want
and let me just say there's no replacing
Lionel Richie just for the record I'll
get that can you get that in a note send
that a note we're gonna put that on a
shirt
are you guys gonna be part of next
week's show oh very good I'm glad you
said that yeah we are going to be ready
for this live from the castle as only we
could do which is fantastic I mean let's
just talk about Cinderella laying all
over again American royalty with you oh
my God but you know it the fact that
we're gonna slip in a side door and be
in the room yo you'll cut back and forth
to us but I'm just going to say it is
it's going to be an incredible
experience
[Music]
foreign